let's say that we have two populations
so that's the first population and this
is the second population right over here
and we are going to think about the
means of these populations so let's say
this first population is the population
of golden retrievers and this second
population is the population of
chihuahuas and the mean that we're going
to think about is maybe the mean weight
so mu 1 would be the mean the true mean
weight of the population of golden
retrievers
and mu2 would be the true mean weight of
the population of chihuahuas and what we
want to think about is what is the
difference between these two population
means between these two population
parameters
well if we don't do if we don't know
this all we can do is try to estimate it
and maybe construct some type of
confidence interval and that's what
we're going to talk about in this video
so how do we go about doing it well
we've seen this or similar things before
what you would do is you would take a
sample from both populations so from
population 1 here i would take a sample
of size n sub 1 and from that i can
calculate a sample mean so this is a
statistic that is trying to estimate
that and i can also calculate a sample
standard deviation
and i can do the same thing in the
population of chihuahuas if that's what
our population 2 is all about
so i could take a sample and actually
this sample does not have to be the same
as n1 so i'll call it n sub 2. it could
be but doesn't have to be
and from that i can calculate a sample
mean
x bar sub 2 and a sample standard
deviation
so now assuming that our conditions for
inference are met and we've talked about
those before we have the random
condition we have the normal condition
we have the independence condition
assuming those conditions are met and we
talk about those in other videos for
means let's think about how we can
construct a confidence interval and so
you might say all right well that would
be the difference of my sample means
x bar sub 1 minus x bar sub 2
plus or minus
some z value
times my standard deviation
times the standard deviation
of the sampling distribution of the
difference of the sample means
so x bar sub 1 minus x bar
sub 2.
and you might say well where do i get my
z from well our confidence level would
determine that confidence
confidence level if our confidence level
is 95
that would determine our z
now this would not be incorrect but we
face a problem
because we are going to need to estimate
what the standard deviation of the
sampling distribution of the difference
between our sample means actually is
to make that clear let me write it this
way so the variance of the sampling
distribution of the difference of our
sample means
is going to be equal to
the variance of the sampling
distribution of sample mean one
plus the variance of the sampling
distribution of sample mean 2.
now if we knew the true underlying
standard deviations of this population
and this population then we could
actually come up with these in that case
this right over here would be equal to
the variance of the population of
population one
divided by our sample size
n one
plus
the variance of the underlying
population 2
divided by this sample size
but we don't know these variances and so
we try to estimate them so we estimate
them with our sample standard deviations
so we say this is going to be
approximately equal to our first sample
standard deviation squared
over
n1 plus our second
sample standard deviation squared
over
n2
and so we can say that an estimate of
the standard deviation of the sampling
distribution of the difference between
our sample means an estimate is going to
be equal to the square root of this it's
going to be approximately equal to the
square root of s1 squared over n1 plus
s2 squared over n2
but the problem is is once we use this
estimate that we can figure out a
critical z value isn't going to be as
good as a critical t value
so instead you would say my confidence
interval is going to be x bar sub 1
minus x bar sub 2 plus or minus
a critical t value instead of a z value
because that works better when you are
estimating
standard deviation of the sampling
distribution of the difference between
the sample means and so you have t star
times
our estimate of this
which is going to be equal to the square
root of s sub 1 squared over n1 plus s
sub 2 squared over n2 and then you might
say well what determines our t star well
once again you would look it up on a
table using your confidence level and
you might be saying wait hold on when i
look up a t value i don't just care
about a confidence level i also care
about degrees of freedom what are what
is going to be the degrees of freedom in
this situation well there's a simple
answer and a complicated answer once we
think about the difference of means
there's fairly sophisticated formulas
that computers can use to get a more
precise degrees of freedom but what you
will typically see in a statistics class
is a conservative view of degrees of
freedom where you take the lower of n1
and n2 and you subtract 1 from that so
the degrees of freedom here
so the degrees of freedom here is going
to be the lower
lower of n one minus one
or
n two minus one or you take the lower of
n one or n two and you subtract one from
that in future videos we will work
through examples that do this